and welcome back to the channel we are
live yet again for our fifth
meet the expert oh boy what a journey
we have been on we've been down deep
into the ocean
we've met with experts who study bears
we've been out in hungary to see
venomous snakes
we have been across the world chatting
to fantastic
inspirational scientists and experts and
conservationists from all over the world
our national geographic fellows
about their incredible research and
today is no different
i'm sad to say that today is the last of
our meet the expert
series but we thought we'd go out with
an absolute bang with our fantastic
guest today kevin mclean who i'll
introduce to you very shortly but before
i do i've talked about this before i've
talked about the mysteries
of rainforests and how they're a full
sensory experience
and if you're watching and you've been
in the middle of a rainforest you know
that your eyes are often drawn high up
into the canopy of those trees it's a
world that we know
very little about it's full of mystery
it's full of sounds you may see
tree fall you may see a blur moving from
tree to tree you may hear noises howler
monkeys
there's a lot that we don't know about
that world up
in the canopy and that's where we are
going today
now if you're new around here hello i'm
lizzy daly i'm a biologist and wildlife
tv host
here to bring you yet another fantastic
live q a
and if you are new around here if you
know the drill then i want to hear from
you get your questions into us live
today into our fantastic guest kevin
maclean who's going to answer all your
fantastic tropical rainforest questions
about the mysteries
high up in the canopy and we want to
hear from you we want to hear
what your favorite tree dwelling species
may be and so do get in touch throughout
today's live now
our guest today so exciting as a
biologist i get super excited about the
idea that there's still
so much on this planet that we don't
know there's still so much mystery out
there and it's kevin's job
to essentially bust that myth yeah he's
an
ecologist he essentially spends his life
studying wildlife high up in the
canopies of of trees from across the
world he's been to panama he's been to
the ecuadorian
amazon he's been to borneo and he has
seen and tracked
so many different species by using
motion sensor cameras
to capture new behaviors and new animals
that we just don't
know enough about and he really has
tracked it all
from three-toed sloths to anteaters to
flying squirrels
this is a man who knows so much about
this strange and wonderful environment
and he's here
with us live hello kevin hey how's it
going
it's i tell you what it's just got a lot
better for me
i i am amazed by your job you know as a
scientist you have kind of this idea of
what it's going to be like you literally
live up to that expectation in your job
it's incredible
yeah yeah it's pretty it's pretty
exciting thank you so much for for
having me it's been really exciting to
see what the
what some of the other scientists have
been up to as well for sure and
and your job i think it's fair to say is
is very specialist but actually quite
general and i'm going to go into a
little bit about what you actually do
with your
cameras a bit later on but i want to
start with perhaps the most obvious
place is
living or breathing and researching in
this environment that we
really know little about why high up in
the canopy of rainforest what was it
about these environments that inspired
you
uh man gosh that's a question that i
definitely continued to ask myself as
things got more and more inconvenient um
but yeah you know i think like they're
in a lot of the research that is is done
um
in in especially in remote places we
like it can be
sort of influenced by like what we kind
of have access to
what is is most um what's more
like easy easiest to get to um so places
that are
are like difficult for us as people to
to access
tend to have less information less
research and it doesn't mean that
they're less important or anything like
that it's just
um you know that's not where the that
effort is concentrated so i
i sort of saw i saw that there at the
time i was starting
starting a lot of this research there
was a lot of a lot of new methods in
terms of using these camera traps and
and how to how to like count up
populations based on all those photos
um but it was all on the ground um and
uh
and i was really interested you know in
rainforest in particular
the majority of mammal species spend at
least part of their life
up in the trees whether they're foraging
up there or sleeping up there and some
of them live
their entire lives um so it's and
and a lot of those species are really
important to the forest as a whole
um so i just knew that there was a
little bit of a a gap in terms of what
our knowledge was
um and wanted to sort of jump in there
yeah and
jump in there you really did um i mean i
rattled off a few of the places that
you've worked you know panama and borneo
what has been your favorite experience
in in the middle of a rainforest do you
have a favorite is that an
unfair to ask oh man gosh that's that
that's a really
it is a really tough question because
you know like the
[Music]
at sort of a really base level just like
being up in that uh in the
in the canopy is a very different
experience
um a very different view like literally
of a forest
we're so used to to looking just looking
up at everything and
having everything looked down and then
you get you know
like 50 meters up into up into a tree
and all of a sudden
the birds are flying below you and
you're looking eye to eye at
another animal you know uh at the next
tree next to you
so um you know i think that the animals
get as confused as
as anyone else is that i'm up there but
um
but it's definitely you know i it's just
a very
very special experience and i think it's
not it's not easy to get up there but i
think
i i always have this this uh sort of
reminder at the beginning of
a new field project where the first time
i get up into another tree i like get up
there and like oh yeah this is
this is cool this is why i'm doing this
it's it's it's really amazing it's a
part of the forest
that one we're we don't spend a lot of
time in but also
that you know there's just not a lot of
people that get to have this view and
it's a really really special experience
just to be there
yeah um we actually got the most
glorious picture on the screen
yeah it's a really uh it's it's a tough
smile to love i guess but uh yeah so
this is a
a dusky leaf monkey this is in penang in
malaysia
um and this is their their they're smart
animals it's
a monkey type of langer um and this
guy's just checking out the camera the
the cameras themselves
they're not um they're like not totally
inconspicuous it look
look like this um and uh
so you know it's like a hunk of plastic
that that wasn't there the day before
and
probably smells like me a little bit and
so they come up and check it out and we
just happened to catch this one
kind of mugging mugging for the camera a
little bit
very curious animals more of those
pictures later on because um
um you have done a lot with camera traps
and obviously setting up this
environment is really important part of
what you do
um but you mentioned a few things
happening no birds flying
underneath you um if someone is watching
it hasn't been into a rainforest
how can you uh convey what it's like to
be in this environment and
and to really be up high in this
mysterious part of this environment
how would you best describe it oh man
that's a good question
i i mean i think part of it is like it
takes so much work to get up there just
from like you know getting getting your
equipment up there and then hauling
yourself up there
you know you you're by the time you get
up into the canopy inevitably you're
just
sort of catching your breath and it's
it's kind of kind of like that moment if
you've ever
like um you know hiked up a mountain or
something like that
for at some point like just before you
get to the top you're just so exhausted
that all you're thinking about
is just being tired and then you finally
get a chance to stop and you look around
and that's that's sort of what it what
it feels like that's sort of the best
the best like um the best comparison i
can make is like
for a long time you're just focusing on
your own
your own well-being and then you stop
and look around
so right and i love how you just kind of
whisked off oh yeah you just go up a
tree
everyone that's watching i mean let's
for example i was in borneo last year
the tallest
uh yellow marante tree the tourist 330
feet is it like 100 meters
yeah just enormous so tell me the
process of
going into the rainforest and lugging up
all that gear that can be what 80 pounds
in weight
yeah yeah definitely um yeah it's it's
it's no
um it's not exactly uh an easy process
that's for sure and i think
as i started doing this i realized why
there hadn't been so many people doing
canopy research yeah so this is
this is all the equipment um this isn't
necessarily what i would bring up in one
trip but
this is what i would bring into the
field like for for an expedition of some
kind
um so um so yeah yeah like
it starts off um we i
i go out into the forest without any any
like climbing gear at all and i'm just
looking for trees
that um that will be sort of good for
whatever project we're
working on sometimes we're looking for
fruiting trees sometimes we're looking
for trees that we know animals nest in
other times we're just looking for trees
we know they move through but they're
not feeding in
so it depends on what it is and you go
and identify all those trees
and then also um you uh you're looking
at sort of the general health of that
tree
um you have to look for any any rotting
at the base or any
branches that aren't aren't um aren't
looking so
so good or and making sure that the
vegetation is really full on the
those trees because you're you're
literally putting your life on all those
branches so i spend a lot of time just
looking looking at sort of the general
health of the tree
looking to see if there's like wasp or
bee nests or something like that that i
might run into
um so all of that happens before i even
like bring a rope out
and then from there uh yeah the way we
get into the trees i have i have this
really long a really tall slingshot um
it's maybe like seven or eight feet tall
um and i
there's like a little bean bag yeah this
is a friend of mine that was was using
it there's a little like
sort of bean bag thing in in the
slingshot that's attached to a string
that goes into that that little box
and so we shoot that that little bean
bag that weight bag over a branch
that gets the string over the branch and
then we can tie
the rope to that string and then we can
pull the rope over
and we'll either attach the rope up at
the top of the branch or we'll attach it
back down on the ground depending on how
tall the tree is
and then i can just climb up how many
shots how many shots has it
oh gosh i
i will always i will um a lot
at least a half day for um for shooting
a line into the tree because i just
never know there there have been times
very few
where i get it in like you know two or
three shots or something
um but i've also spent three days trying
to get into one tree that i knew i had
to get into
so yeah i i mean also you know i like
didn't
i don't know i like i didn't use giant
slingshots as a child so i had to learn
how to do this
like i didn't have a lot of like history
of practice or anything
so when i first started doing it and
doing it i was bad at it and so you just
have to like
get better and better and keep
practicing and yeah and
yeah and all jokes aside i mean you are
in a a dense environment as it is and of
course you've got all those
variables to deal with yeah animals in
that environment and conditions etc
so it's a difficult it's a difficult job
before you even begin right really
yeah yeah yeah i mean you know most of
the places that i've worked
recently um there we've had trails to
to sort of get to to certain parts of
the the research site um but then at
some point you'll see a tree like
sticking up above the rest so then you
have to get yourself to that tree
so you end up going off trail you know
falling down falling down hills and
you know sliding in the mud and whatnot
um and
and yeah yeah you just um it's it's
it's there's a lot of very dense
vegetation so some of the
the challenge when you get to that tree
is finding just
a little hole in that vegetation that
you can shoot the line through
and the lines just get stuck on
everything and
you know like they it's it's not not an
easy process
but i think you that you know i think
untangling string
at this point is now like a therapeutic
exercise for me
if anything so um so yeah you just spend
a lot of time
arguing with string essentially so
do you have any particular stories that
really stand out for you you know a
particular journey to find
a certain tree or a tree that you've
spent a lot of time in
carrying out your research um yeah
that's that's another good question
actually you know what the the the
photo that you just showed of of me up
in that tree that there's
you know like that i've climbed many
many many trees at this point um i don't
always remember
all of them but that one that one that
that you showed i definitely
do because that was one of them where i
i spent um i i spent half of the like
the
afternoon of one day one entire day and
then the morning of another day trying
to get that shot it's it's really hard
to tell you know like from from where
where uh this picture is taken
but you know it was a it was actually a
a sort of
large like a long distance from from the
trunk of the tree
which makes shooting it a little bit
harder and then uh
there was a small window that we had to
get get
uh the the weight bag through uh on on
that branch so that it wouldn't hit
another like another branch above it and
everything so it just took
tons and tons and tons of shots and then
at some point you just get tired and
and you get frustrated and you know some
choice words
are used and you just have to take a
break and you know eat a sandwich or
something and then come back to it
um but yeah it's it's really
you know it really it tests your your
patience in a lot of ways for sure
i can only imagine what i like about
these stories is it's the the real side
of sometimes being scientists
and actually it takes integrity and
perseverance and
all of that comes with before even
setting up a camera trap which is
fabulous i want to talk about that um
shortly but before we do
once you're up in a tree you're in that
environment there's lots going on around
you
what's the process then how long are you
in that tree for
and is there anything that happens to
you in like like where do you go to the
bathroom
tell me the basics oh goodness yeah
really just getting into the personal
details of it um
yeah no i i mean i uh i try
to not have to go to the bathroom in the
tree at all actually i don't think i've
ever had to do that
um but um but uh
i yeah i just you know like it it really
depends on what the tree is so yeah and
this photo you can see
like off to the right there's a there's
a camera um
that is down that branch um and you can
see my ro
the white rope going off there so in
this in this tree in particular i
not only had to go straight up but i had
to move laterally into the tree so i had
to shoot the line over that that first
first branch and then i had to toss that
other
another weight bag over to the branch
that the the white rope is around now
and so that process can take forever as
well it's it's sort of
it's weird it's almost like uh like
playing some sort of weird carnival game
where you're like tossing the
the weight bag to get over the branch
and then you're just pulling on the
string a bunch of times to get it to
swing
back to you in the right direction so it
like
it's um i don't know like in a weird way
like th
those are the the some of the skills i
developed the most while i was in grad
school which was not something i was
really expecting
um i don't know i mean i wouldn't want
to like wager any bets right now but i
i will say i like i i'm pretty pretty
humble about most of my skills and
knowledge but i will say i'm pretty good
at swinging a weight bag in a tree
so yeah so you probably the best person
to take to a carnival
actually as you just get
[Laughter]
yeah and then um again you just talk
so casually about you know some of these
skills but they're so necessary and
picking those
those correct lateral branches are
integral getting the right footage that
you need right
so tell me more how many camera shops
would you set up in a tree
and what is it that you're trying to
capture yeah i mean
again it again sort of depends on the
project i especially when i was first
starting
you know it takes so much um uh
it takes so much time to get
up into that tree i wanted that all of
that effort to be for something
um but i so i would set up
a whole bunch of cam i would set up
three or four cameras in a single tree
which then adds even more time because
you have to having to get to three or
four different points and treat like
once you get into the center of the
crown
you can kind of look around and see
where a camera could go
and where animals might be walking from
one branch to the next you can really
see
where certain branches connect to each
other where animals might be moving
so you can spot those those places um
but it does
it takes a long time so i i would put
initially i would put a bunch of cameras
into a single tree
just because i was really nervous about
not getting anything and like you know
just like sort of having nightmares
about an animal moving through my tree
and not actually going by my camera
so um but uh but yeah i think
over time you know you you uh you sort
of figure out the the best places to put
things the places that are most
realistic to actually get yourself and a
camera too
um and sometimes you know it's more
important to have
cameras in a bunch of different trees um
like have more cameras spread out
throughout the forest rather than a
concentration of cameras
in a few trees so and you mentioned
earlier that sometimes you put them in
fruiting trees or
near nests yeah would you ever put one
say near an orangutan nest and born you
or
oh goodness i would not want to go near
an orangutan's nest
um but i uh safety as well
yeah yeah i i i do you know i i
am never like purposely going anywhere
that i know i'm going to
encounter an animal in in the tree you
know the
during the most of the species in the
canopy are actually nocturnal they're
active at night so they're definitely
there there have definitely been plenty
of trees i've been in
where there were animals sleeping
somewhere in like in the trunk or in a
nest above me or something like that
but i'm trying to do my best to not
disturb what
is already there um i i've not you know
i i've not
um done a lot in terms of just like
specifically monitoring one
nest um but we are really we're often
looking more at
sort of the population of species or the
community of species
that's coming through a certain point um
in the forest
so um yeah i i i
i really sort of do my best not to
disturb what's up there
um and leave it in the same condition
that it was in
yeah and and obviously anyone that's
been in rain forest i mean you'd rarely
see it happen anyway someone being high
canopy but you guys professionals you
know what you're doing so so important
to get in and out
um yeah without any disturbance um
i have a question that's come in is the
tallest tree
out of to to wow suburb of borneo island
was the question about that yellow
marante um that
is that's a good question you know this
is something that has has
uh continued to change actually also
pretty recently there's a few different
research groups that have been
identifying the tallest tropical trees
in the world the tallest trees in the
world are in california the
the giant redwoods but the tallest
tropical trees
are these uh dipterocarp trees which is
is what the
the the person is is asking about and um
they uh so while i was in borneo one
year
there they had just made an announcement
like a year a year prior that they had
found the tallest tropical tree in the
world they sent a team out to go and
measure it
and then while i was there someone else
found another taller tropical tree
and so then they had to go send out
their team and so it i i actually
haven't kept up on the news of it
exactly but um but denim valley wow
like there's there's a bun there's a few
different pockets of
old growth forest that have huge huge
trees
absolutely and for anyone uh watching
that's interested in that um
yeah that that story in itself is
particularly interesting
and um they go out and helicopters and
do survey air surveys of
of those trees and it's really down to
identifying a tall tree right and then
measuring it yeah yeah they can find
them with um they use
what's called lidar like the the laser
version of radar
and so uh they can find find the
like potential candidate trees uh with
that and then they'll send a team on the
ground to actually like
get a tape measure um and and actually
like measure the whole thing in
in person so that's a giant tape measure
um so your camera traps are up now in
these trees positioned perfectly
tell us about some of the things you've
seen you must have captured some
incredible things
yeah i mean i think the the really
interesting thing is that like because
especially when i started i think
there's there's um there are more groups
and more researchers that are doing
canopy camera trap work now which is
really great
um but when i started i just like
anything i got was really exciting and
yeah anything we got was something
something different something new not
necessarily
a species we didn't know about but um or
you know something new like a new
species altogether
but it was uh you know you're capturing
behavior you're capturing
um you know interaction sometimes with
with species that we just don't see
very often um and uh yeah
i mean this is like a huge huge iguana
that uh was was
living in one of the trees that i set up
cameras in
and it's funny because the cameras are
they're um
they have an infrared motion sensor so
usually it's something that is warm that
is moving
and that's that's why they're meant for
mammals but this iguana
um actually it was sunning itself on a
branch so it got
its body temperature was much warmer and
then it moved into the shade where the
camera was so
it had enough of a temperature
differential um between
uh the environment that it set up set
off the camera
so fantastic yeah so i mean you do see a
real variety of species is there a
particular
encounter or thing that you've i should
say thing you've captured on a camera
that's kind of really caught your
attention or caught your eye or amazed
you
yeah um yeah i think um i think
one of uh well actually when i was in
borneo i was really excited because they
the bornea and southeast asia in general
sort of like
the the hot spot for squirrel and flying
squirrel biodiversity and i
really like squirrels i love flying
squirrels um
and i you know i had sort of like kind
of just to some extent had like
decidedly gone to this part of the world
just because i wanted to see so many of
these squirrels yeah so this is a
a red giant squirrel um it kind of
they're actually it's you know again
there's no like size reference here but
the
they can get up to basically around the
size of a house cat
essentially this is the largest squirrel
in the world
um they have that that membrane that
goes from their wrist to their ankle
that helps them glide
and so they live in these super super
tall trees um and that's how they they
get around they're
they're nocturnal they come out at night
and they
they'll come out of their nest and
they'll glide to the neck to another
tree and climb up to the top of that
they eat
mostly leaves um so they're just gliding
around the forest looking for
for young leaves that they can they can
eat
they are incredible gliders i was so
lucky we were just saying before we were
on i was so lucky to see a gliding
um flying squirrel and it is the most
spectacular thing you will ever see
this it was of course at night time
travelling this is from these giant
trees um from one to another and that
that particular
screenshot so here we go there's some
more oh yeah yeah so this is this is
actually
in in the same tree um i got photos of
that giant flying squirrel that giant
red giant flying squirrel and this is a
uh
a pygmy flying squirrel which is
actually the smallest squirrel species
in the world
um they are they they weigh i think
about um
20 to 22 grams which is like about the
weight of a double a battery
um if if you can sort of imagine that um
but uh they're really really tiny i was
really excited to get to get one of
these you can see him
landing over on the left and then he
kind of checks out the camera and takes
off i really wish that i'd gotten better
photos of the of them
but um but yeah it's i i was really
excited to get those
and the other thing that i didn't didn't
realize until i
actually saw some of these squirrels in
in real life and also
you know um did a little bit more um
just sort of uh digging in in the
literature is
there you know i always thought of
flying squirrels as you know they
they leap they glide and then they just
sort of end up where
in the direction so there's a lot of a
lot of um importance on
on the direction they jump but they can
actually they they have muscles in that
membrane so they can
squeeze them on one side squeeze them on
the other they can they use their tail
as a rudder so they can actually
really direct the their um their
trajectory
as they're gliding so they can go around
trees
um and they as they come come to the
tree they're gonna land they slow
themselves down they make sort of like a
little bit of a j pattern
and then they they have like a little
thump on the bottom
wow we can learn so much from flying
squirrels let me tell you but
it's um they're fabulous but just that i
mean
those pictures that you've shown us
there few very different species in one
tree i mean you talk about
communities of species what what does
something like that mean
yeah i mean i think there's what's
really interesting is like i
because i'm setting up a camera that's
in one static position
you know like you you think of i don't
know sometimes you think of
uh like the habitat of an animal is like
it's their territory and they're
defending it all the time but the
reality is like
there are lots of species that are kind
of overlapping in their territories and
lots of individuals sometimes as well
and that's sort of what we think what
we're talking about when we talk about a
community
it's different species may be different
individuals of the same species that are
utilizing a similar environment and in
this case
they're you know those those big trees
that they're in um sometimes they're
they're looking for leaves
to be eating in the the big tree itself
but actually it's the structure that
that is really important for these
flying squirrels because it's a huge
huge tree that sticks up above the rest
of the forest so it provides like a
really great
jumping point to to get to the next if
you're if you're
going to rely on gliding then you have
to you have to go from a higher place to
a lower place right
right so that's why these these like
giant lollipops of trees
sticking up above the forest like works
works so well for them
um absolutely fantastic um we have some
more questions coming in
what's your favorite animal that you've
seen in a tree kevin
what's yeah also
really really tough i mean the thing is
like there's there are
a lot of species that i've seen on the
cameras that uh like from the photos
that i have never seen in real life just
because
you know i'm out there during the day uh
and you know they're mostly going by at
night
um uh i have i have spent the night in a
tree before but i didn't see a whole lot
other than like lightning off in the
distance so
um so but yeah i think my favorite
favorite animal that i have uh have
actually seen
um out in out like up in the tree
was um actually probably not not even
not even
a mammal even though that's sort of what
what i focus on i really loved
seeing um some of the hornbill species
in borneo
um because you see them again you're
like up really high
they are not necessarily landing in in
the trees that are
are even up at your level so you're kind
of watching them
um watching them from from above they're
you know
landing on a perch and then you know
passing passing food to each other
and you can what's really crazy is uh
when
they're flying close to you can hear the
the like they're like ligaments and
tendons moving their wings they're
actually they're
they're it's not like an owl that flies
silently they're like really noisy um in
their
their uh how they you know in in their
flight
um but yeah i don't know the other one
in panama also is uh
the rothschilds porcupine is a really is
a favorite of mine
i don't know why yeah i don't know why i
i just i have always been really partial
to porcupines i grew up
um i grew up in uh in minnesota actually
in the us
yeah so and so you know this is
obviously different than the porcupines
that we have in the u.s
they the quills are much much shorter um
but uh but they're just like such an
interesting animal they live their whole
lives up and
up in the the trees they have that you
can see their tail it's a
a prehensile tail so they can actually a
grip with that tail they can hang upside
down if they need to
it provides a fifth limb um and i think
like i i don't know i can't explain why
i i
am drawn to porcupines but i think to
see see these guys and see them see
get photos of them was really really um
just really fun and not something i was
expecting i think the first
the first sight that i got photos of
them in panama i didn't even know that
they were in the area um
everyone else did i just didn't know but
still
yeah yeah and you i guess i guess for
you you have a completely different
perspective on
some of these species which are strictly
arboreal completely tree dwelling
and of course having those moments with
animals you wouldn't normally like the
hornbills you talked about must just be
fascinating absolutely fascinating
really great
um we've got a question that's come in
here um what does a forest canopy mean
um is it multiple trees forming a canopy
shape i've talked about canopy quite a
lot but can you kind of
help explain that a bit yeah yeah no
that's that's a very
very valid question you know i think we
sometimes when we're when i'm
talking about my work or other other
thing you know you you
lock in these words that maybe just
aren't meaningful to other people
necessarily but
um we when we talk about the canopy of
of
a forest we're talking about the layer
of where
like one crown of a tree like the the
leafy part of the tree
meets the next so it's if you were to
sort of take
look at a forest like in a cross section
like looking at it from the side
you'd see sort of the forest floor at
the bottom you'd see
the understory which is sort of where
all the trunks are and maybe there's a
little bit of vegetation and then at the
tops of all these trees where the
the leaves meet each other that's what
we call
the canopy fantastic there you go um
i have to ask you sweat drinking bees
tell me about that
oh my gosh yeah um yeah
so i um there's there are a lot of
species especially in
uh in the forest that like they are
limited like they're nutrient limited so
they're always looking for
salt or other other nutrients that they
need in their diet
to like make make their bodies function
and so
um sweat is something you know you're i
am always i'm just a very sweaty person
and so
um whenever yeah exactly
um so whenever i like uh i've often been
climbing like this and
and these these are these are bees
they're actually they're stingless bees
which is good but that
they can't actually bite um which is why
i'm looking a little bit nervous
there um but i was just like so sweaty
and all
the this whole like group of bees found
me and they're just it's like and you
can't even see
all of them that are on there they like
went all the way across my back
as well um but they uh yeah they were
just
just there like drinking my sweat and
trying to
you know replenish their salts um i
don't if you ever go for like
a really long run like you you have to
hydrate but you also have to take in
um take in um you know salts and
and yeah electrolytes to to sort of keep
keep that moisture and that's that's all
that they're
they're doing is trying to get all the
salt off my back
you don't look best pleased about it i
don't know
but i'm sure it's little moments like
that in this environment that perhaps
you would never think of
oh my gosh yeah i'm sure you've got so
many
different stories about that um have you
don't mean to kind of feel damning but
have you had any kind of
uh scary moments because i think a lot
of people watching will be thinking oh
hundreds of feet up in in the sky in a
very unfamiliar environment
is yeah i mean the thing is
in the grand scheme of things i am i'm
actually like a
pretty like risk-averse person which is
why i spend so much time
like evaluating the safety of a tree and
testing things out we like
do a bunch of tests on the rope before
we climb but at the end of the day it is
you know it's dangerous to go up there
and you you know
you're mostly almost every tree i climb
in
nobody else has climbed so it's not like
there's like
there's somebody else that's checked it
out for you in advance like you just you
don't really know
um so yeah i mean i've i've definitely
had times where
i got um you know i shot my shot the
line over got my rope in
and then um you know tested it we do
what's called a bounce test where i'll
i'll bounce on the rope first and then
i'll get another person to bounce on the
rope with me
and you know that that combined weight
you know if it's holding holding both of
us then it should be okay for me
um and you know sometimes you do all of
that and you get
you get up into it into the tree and you
just you hear
you hear a cracking you hear something
and and that
that is really really sort of like makes
makes your
your blood go cold um but yeah yeah so
this is
this was one of those one of those times
where i i had done all the tests i had
examined this tree um and it wasn't even
the branch that i was
on it was a branch that my rope had
actually been leaning against
was not very healthy and i hadn't
noticed it and i got maybe
10 or 12 feet up in in the tree and i
heard
a crack and then all of a sudden i was
only six feet up in the tree
and this branch was hanging just
dangling right above me
and so i uh i had to because it was
dangling it was like kind of close to a
trail it was a little bit dangerous so
i ended up re-rigging my rope climbing
up the other side of the tree
and then breaking that branch the rest
of the way
and pushing it pushing it down on the
forest floor so that it wouldn't fall on
anyone else
but yeah that's that's the branch that
almost like fell right on top of me
uh yeah yeah scary i'm sure and and i
guess
something that just comes with the job
and why you need highly skilled people
like yourselves yeah
some of those skills but they're very
important exactly actually you know what
now that i'm thinking about it i
i am now recalling that i so once i
climbed up the other side
i um i was climbing up there and i
um i was about to sort of move towards
that branch i put my hand on the trunk
of the tree
and i happened to put my hand on top of
a wasp nest
oh it was like out of a cartoon like a
stream of wasp coming out
they're like swarming around my head
biting and stinging everything so then i
i i just like closed my eyes and got
like got out of the tree
and actually like the and the one of my
climbing instructors
that i i worked with when i was first
starting he used to make us do
all of our skills like rig like setting
up setting up our gear on the rope and
climbing up and coming back down and
everything changing over our ropes
he made us do that all uh close with our
eyes closed he made us tie our knots
behind our back so that it was like
really built into our muscle memory and
that was that was why you know like i
had
i couldn't see i had to like close close
close my eyes
my ears were like my ear and my cheek
was starting to swell already from the
bites
um and and that's why that's what you
you sort of prepare for the worst
because sometimes it
like you know bad things can actually
happen yeah
and also to be clear after that happened
i just sat on the tree
on the trail and cried for a little
while it was rough
oh no i hope you're happy
it comes with the job i'm sure there's
there's big
big risks involved with what you do um
absolutely fast
that's an eating stuff now um you've
seen a lot you've seen a lot with your
camera traps you've seen a lot yourself
you have to be fit you have to be
prepared you have to as i say have
integrity
i've talked about you working with
three-toed sloths before and sloths in
general
what's this about you actually getting
goodness
caught up in a race with a sloth yeah so
the thing is the thing you realize
also is like you know we i get all this
equipment i have the ropes i have all
this
the this uh you know gear to sort of
stabilize me and help me move in the
tree
but at the end of the day like i'm just
you know i'm like not
equipped physically to be up there right
like i'm not
i don't we don't have like the claws or
the tails or anything like that to
actually be up in that tree and we think
of slaws as being these like very very
slow animals which i guess they sort of
are but at the end of the day they're
like
they're much better they're much better
at being in a tree than i am
um and so i was setting up a camera and
i was trying to get myself
um from like near the trunk to about
five feet away so i'd get to the right
the right spot for the camera and in the
time i was trying to move like five feet
in front of me there was a sloth kind of
like this one
that had was had you know woken up in
the tree next to me
it had moved into the tree that i was in
and then had moved on to the tree
past me all in the time that i was
trying to move like five feet in front
of me it was
like infuriating but also just like yeah
of course he's he's good at this like
that's why he can do that
i love i just love that kind of
comparison oh i've got been
beaten by a sloth it's um it's fantastic
um
we've got another question here what's
your least favorite animal you've seen
in a tree i feel like you may have just
touched on this from your
negative experience but um is there one
that particularly just continues to crop
up and
and uh you know i don't know i don't
want to like animal shame any of the
species that are up there but
um i think i think the the animals that
i
tend to have the most problems with
are ants and this is nothing against
ants they're really amazing
animals like there's so many different
species they're really amazing engineers
up in the trees and down on the ground
um and they're they're also they also
happen to be very good at
uh defending their the tree that they
live in and sometimes they actually have
a
symbiotic relationship with that tree
and since a lot of times i'm setting up
trees in
or setting up cameras in fruiting trees
um like figs or something like that
a lot of times it means i'm running into
ants that are trying to
to defend that tree um and so those are
like you know like ants
sometimes they're like really really big
ones that um
that just sort of swarm you other times
other times it's little ones that will
sort of get everywhere that you can
you can imagine and just like pulling
them out of out of my shirt and
everywhere else
but um there's like and in the amazon
they have these
bullet ants um which have have uh
i've encountered them a couple times
it's really really painful to
to uh to get bit by them so
yeah i think i i again i have nothing
against
ants like in my day-to-day life
but uh i will say the most sort of
adversarial relationship i've had with
an animal
has been enhanced is without i
understand that entirely
um there's been some amazing pictures
you've shown us um
you mentioned that you haven't
necessarily had you know hundreds of
firsts but you have had some
pretty rare species right can you tell
us more about some of the more rare ones
that you suspect
uh yeah what so one of the one of the
species that i
um i was really really excited about
it's not uh
there's it's called a bushy-tailed
possum and
um it's just you know like it's not like
it's a
it's not necessarily like a critically
endangered species or not right
on the endangered species list like you
would think
it's not um not even one that you know
it shows up
in all parts of the amazon actually has
a pretty big range
but it's just one that it's it's small
it's only out at night
and um just i hadn't really shown up on
any other wildlife surveys that had been
done in the area i was working in
and so it was just like really really
special to like capture photos of this
animal
alive out in the forest you know like
the i looked through
other sort of scientific records of the
of this
um this uh species and the other records
were at
times you know when they had been
logging in a forest and they found one
of these species and then they
you know killed it and sent it to a
museum and and have that specimen
but like there's just very few records
of people seeing them
like alive out in the forest or or just
even in this case like having
having photographic evidence of them um
they're they're pretty just very rare to
to see or document
um and so it was really special to be
able to capture you know i i found
or in uh different cameras i think we
collected maybe
60 or 70 photos of them um
and it's just uh you know like it's
again like i said it's not like we're
finding a new species it's not like
we're
we're there's you know something we
thought was extinct is coming back or
anything like that but it is really
special to just know that
that you're you're adding an important
record of a species that we don't really
know much about because we
almost never see it um and that's that's
sort of like the only way we can learn
any
anything more about animals is is to to
find them
yeah and it's super exciting and super
valuable for that exact reason
what would you like the people watching
to learn from your
your work and and what you do
you know i think i think one of the main
sort of
lessons of doing all of this is uh kind
of what we we touched on at the
beginning
is that like our our understanding of a
lot of ecosystems a lot of
um a lot of species uh is is really
biased by
our own viewpoint we we are ground
dwelling animals ourselves so we know a
lot more about the forest floor
or that's part of why like the deep sea
is so
mysterious to us as well because like
it's really hard for us to get down
there
um and so but but there's there's
really interesting uh life there's a lot
of
really interesting processes that go on
um the canopy itself is real
really important i mean it's where most
of the photosynthesis in the forest
happens and
you know there's just like a lot of
things going on and and sort of taking
this
this approach of of recognizing that
places are maybe inconvenient to get to
um but may have sort of some payoff in
spending time learning about them um
that's sort of been the big
the biggest lesson is you know the for
for
for me at least like some of the things
that that have been most
impactful and most interesting and most
meaningful for me
came at in places that were really
really hard to access
um and and that's just sort of a lesson
that you know we
we um we know a lot about the things
that we're we're close
to and that are in our immediate
surroundings um
and uh and yeah it takes it takes effort
to find new things
and kind of i mean reading about what
you've done it's incredible you've
really been to so many amazing regions
but actually
yourself as a national geographic fellow
in your your project with camera traps
that started that curiosity wasn't it
like what yeah
what can we learn from these
environments yeah yeah absolutely you
know i think the whole
my whole um idea of actually putting
cameras up in the tree was
was from you know i was working on a
survey project on the ground
we were setting up all these cameras and
had spent a ton of time getting out to
one site where we knew we had to set the
camera up and
we we got it running and then an
anteater climbed right over the camera
we had just set up
and so you know like it's wonderful to
see animals but
um but also really infuriating to know
that like
just the the way we were going about
this project
that we were never gonna catch that
animal um
and so it got me thinking more and more
about like what you know this is a
three-dimensional environment we should
be surveying it
in little three dimensions you know yeah
absolutely
oh the coolest job ever um right we have
a few more questions coming in i can't
believe this has gone so quickly
it's been incredible have you ever
fallen from a tree or got injured
um yeah that's another good question i
very thankfully um have not had a bad
fall
you know i think like i said i've had
had uh uh
um experiences where something has has
snapped or broken and i've fought
like i've dropped a little bit but i
haven't fallen all the way to the ground
but i do
you know in meeting other climbers and
other
canopy researchers i am
many of them have had really uh sort of
harrowing experiences
and you know it's it's something and
these are all people that are great
climbers probably better
much better than i am but you just never
quite know and so that
you know it's something that's
nerve-wracking you do everything you can
to
to be safe about it um but um but yeah i
think
i think that's uh that's
that's i i've been very fortunate um
yeah absolutely um and i think close
calls is enough
kevin if you ask me um really
interesting question
do you ever use drones to get a look
through the canopy
for me this is interesting i've spoke to
somebody recently who does
surveys of orangutan nests with drones
um have you ever used drones in the
rainforest
yeah yeah so um i i
don't fly drones myself at all but i
i have i have been been worked on a
project before where we
we set up we were flying a drone over to
sort of
uh do some surveys of other primate
species
um uh this is yeah this is a drone shot
that actually just
uh another researcher who happened to
have a drone took took some photos and
some video of me up in the trees
yeah it's a tree is huge um
but i yeah i don't there's there's a lot
of potential
for using drones up in the trees um it's
not something that i have
i have done necessarily but um but yeah
i think there's
there's some really interesting work
that's been done with them yeah
where was that clip taken that was um
that was in yasuni national park in
ecuador
um so that's a big seba tree um that is
uh
it was like you can see sticking up
above the rest of the forest we actually
we got all the way up there and uh and
there were
orchids up there that um that it was
just sort of like a field of orchids on
one of these huge branches
uh that all smelled like vanilla because
the vanilla
like the vanilla bean that we use is a
is a comes from a type of orchid
and these weren't like the vanilla
orchids but they're something
something related so it was just so
crazy to get all the way up there
and it like smells like cookies or ice
cream whatever
at the top of this incredible yeah um
another question great questions coming
in everyone thank you for sending them
in
um do you see a lot of effects of
climate change in the rainforest and
it's
it's kind of come at a good time because
you mentioned the awkwards
in ecuador and it's my understanding
that they're highly
um they've got a high amount of endemism
right so the
which they live is limited to those
conditions being correct and we're
seeing
climate change change this have you seen
that up in the canopies in ecuador or
any of the places you've studied
yeah i mean i think that that what
exactly what you're saying about
the orchids i mean it's true of a lot of
different species
especially in tropical forests that um
where
they are are sort of in
in a uh like living living at sort of
the limits of their their tolerance for
in different ways and everything like
that so as their
as their the environment around them
shifts um
and and changes their ability like in on
an evolutionary time scale they haven't
had to adapt to things like that because
so in some of these places the
conditions have been so
so constant for for you know centuries
and centuries so
it's things like that you know like
small small changes have a big
big effect on some species there's
there's certainly some species that are
able to move or able to adapt
but others that just really aren't uh
aren't equipped for it
um or or if they are going to adapt we
don't really know how because we haven't
haven't
seen it seen it happen before so there's
just there's a lot that we don't know
and then we there's also some some
species that we know
are really um really affected by by
changes in their environment so
absolutely um fantastic answer to a
really fantastic question
and what responsibility do we hold as
humans conservation
of nature what a what a question it'll
be the last one we can
fit in today but yeah yeah i think
yeah i mean there's there's so many good
answers to this question
i i think um one of the things that
comes to mind for me is that
like you know nature doesn't exist just
you know for us to look at it
we actually we get a lot of benefits
from
nature being around natural habitats and
species and environments
um being around you know the there's
there are um you know the the filtration
of the water
that that a lot of forest can provide
and and providing oxygen
and there's all sorts of things that
that services we call the ecosystem
services that forests and other natural
environments provide
so it's not that just that it's like we
we shouldn't just think of them as like
ornaments for us to
to look at they're actually playing a
really integral part
of our lives and if we lose those
functions then we have to figure out
another way to do it that's not just
being done automatically
in in the environment
absolutely fantastic answer and i'm
always amazed you know you've worked in
biodiversity hotspots i'm always amazed
by the density of wildlife that we have
in these particular habitats and
often you know if you're sat if i'm sat
here in the uk
you know you may feel slightly
disconnected from an area like ecuador
but
we're all connected right um and i'm
sure you've seen that on a
on a large scale with all your travels
oh yeah absolutely and i think you know
like
seeing seeing sort of the connection
between forest
in you know other other places that i've
worked to the communities that surround
them you know it makes it even more
clear how
you know when i come back home i live in
california we we and we
think about our water resources a lot
here um
you know it really reminds you that we
are really
like even here here in california we're
also very connected
to the natural environments around us we
depend on
you know how much snowfall we get in the
mountains every year to fill up our
reservoirs there's so much about
um how we live our lives no matter where
you are in the world that really relies
on
on having a healthy healthy environment
and surroundings
i think that's a lovely message to
finish on um yeah
what a fantastic guys absolutely flown
by i have loved
i could talk to you for hours and hours
um kevin
thank you ever so much for coming on
live yeah thank you so much
it's been a real joy hearing tales from
trees hundreds of feet high and i'm sure
everyone will be following on with your
next adventures when and if they can
continue
um any last things you'd like to add
before we before we sign off
uh no just you know i'm glad that you've
been able to do this it's been really
fun to see what other
the other scientists have been working
on some of them are familiar some are
people
new to me so it's been really really
amazing to just
you know get a chance to feel like i'm
connecting with other other researchers
around
absolutely and we certainly finished on
a fantastic speaker so kevin thank you
so much for joining us and
everyone with their amazing questions
today and throughout the whole of the
series a massive
thank you for tuning in live you know
getting the opportunity to connect with
some fantastic people
carrying out dedicating their lives to
conservation work and work within the
scientific field
from across the world and it's been an
absolute pleasure to be part of the
series an
absolute pleasure to talk to kevin
mclean who is the new tree climber
fan for me i'm going to be following his
work
from here on out up every single tube
from from
forever from here on um massive thank
you all for watching this has been
a joy meet the expert series i've been
your host lizzie daly and hopefully
we'll see you around
soon here on the channel bye